Dear kitten,...
...under my tutelage, you seem to have gotten the hang of this "being a kitten" thing.
I've taught you well.
But you may wonder how I became so knowledgeable.
It may be hard to believe but I too was once a tiny buffoon much like yourself...
...but cuter than you, like, way cuter.
Kind of ridiculous, actually.
When I was a kitten, I lived in a wire box with my brothers and one sister.
My mama wasn't too keen on me being a cage fighter,...
...but that didn't stop me from training day and night.
My dream was to one day take on the beagle that lived on the other side of the room.
That drooly-faced knucklehead was always taunting me.
But that day would never come to fruition.
Instead, my family eventually left.
And there's not a day that goes by that I don't think about them, except my sister.
She's the worst.